[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 pour une
nouvelle émission le 7 8 nous sommes le
mercredi 17 mai voici le programme de ce
soir aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale contre l'homophobie et
également les 10 ans du mariage pour
tous dans cette émission retour sur
l'adoption de cette loi ouvrant le
mariage et l'adoption au couple
homosexuel avec le témoignage de Yann et
Loïc habitant de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
ces derniers se sont mariés en 2013
c'était alors le premier couple
homosexuel à s'unir dans le département
de l'Ain aujourd'hui ils sont parents
d'une petite fille et ont subi des
menaces de mort de leurs voisins amateur
de cinéma ou non vous n'avez pas pu
passer à côté le Festival de Cannes à
débuté hier soir une large page sera
consacrée au septième art nous serons
notamment en compagnie de un jeune de 18
ans originaire de Sartrouville grâce au
projet moteur ce dernier présentera son
court-métrage sur Martin Luther King à
Cannes nous retrouverons également sur
place nos confrères de radio sensation
et enfin comme chaque mercredi Céline
Charles vous donnera ses films à ne pas
manquer cette semaine au programme Fast
and Furious 10 ou encore sublime et puis
à l'approche de ce week-end prolongée
nous vous donnerons également nos idées
de sortie dans les Yvelines théâtre
football ou encore musique le planning
sera varié les détails enfin des
missions et justement avec moi en
plateau ce soir Loïc et Yann Navarro
Chabrier bonsoir à vous deux je reçois
alors je le disais à l'instant vous êtes
le premier couple homosexuel à vous êtes
marié en 2013 dans le département de
l'Ain aujourd'hui vous habitez à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et vous avez une
petite fille Rose qui est justement
derrière nous sur ce plateau on lui dit
aussi bonsoir et donc en cette Journée
internationale contre l'homophobie de
lutte contre l'homophobie et surtout 10
ans après l'adoption de la loi pour le
mariage pour tous est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que les mentalités les
mentalités ont avancé aujourd'hui sur la
question de l'homosexualité oui je pense
que oui
ça reste encore léger mais oui ça
évoluait les menaces que nous on a subi
et je pense qu'on y reviendra tout à
l'heure
on pense tous les deux que c'est que
c'est un cas isolé et c'est souvent des
cas isolés et que ça a bien évolué donc
on en parlera plus largement dans
quelques instants avec nous également un
plateau Youssef bonsoir alors vous avez
participé au projet moteur un concours
de films ouverts au 14 au 22 ans le
challenge faire le portrait d'une
personne qui vous inspire en une minute
trente et donc parmi les 500 jeunes
Youssef vous avez été sélectionnés pour
présenter votre mini film sur Martin
Luther King au Festival de Cannes quel
est votre sentiment qu'est-ce que ça
vous fait d'avoir été sélectionné et de
pouvoir monter les célèbres marches du
le Festival de Cannes je suis très
heureux ça va me permettre de découvrir
un monde plus professionnel et de voir
plus loin et bah c'est la première fois
et que j'ai été pris pour un concours ou
pour allo Festival de Cannes et je suis
très heureux c'est un rêve pour vous
ouais c'est un rêve j'ai commencé ça a
pas marché au début j'ai un petit peu
lâcher après j'ai repris et là je suis
content donc on reviendra sur ce
concours et sur votre mini film tout à
l'heure dans cette émission avec nous
également ce soir en plateau un
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78
Nicolas dandry bonsoir avec vous on
verra les informations à ne pas manquer
aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines dans cette
émission également cette manifestation à
l'aéroport de Toussus-le-Noble les
riverains en ont assez du bruit provoqué
par les avions la chronique et du Talk
de Régine comme chaque mercredi elle
vous fait découvrir une école ou une
formation sur le territoire des Yvelines
mais aussi du sport avec la loterie de
la draft qui a eu lieu cette nuit on
sait dorénavant dans quelle équipe
Victor one va très probablement jouer en
NBA ce sera à découvrir avec notre
chroniqueur de si on parle les sports
Mike mocongo mais avant tout ça je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
matin le soleil continuera de briller
dans les Yvelines le ciel sera
légèrement voilé le matin au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à
Rambouillet ou dans et Versailles et 10
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi le temps devrait se
maintenir sur l'ensemble du département
côté température il fera en moyenne 15 à
16 degrés et demain pas de fête à
souhaiter puisque ce sera à l'ascension
le point maintenant sur les informations
du jour à retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Nicolas dandry
on commence les informations du jour
avec la suite de la tournée des cantons
par Pierre bélier effectivement le
président du conseil départemental des
Yvelines était hier dans le canton de
Chatou l'occasion pour lui et bien de
visiter un centre de recherche et de
développement d'EDF à Chatou et le stade
omnisport de Croissy-sur-Seine pierre
bédiat a aussi rencontré les élus de la
ville du Port-Marly à l'hôtel de ville
vous le voyez sur les images c'est son
cinquième un déplacement dans le
département pour rappel cette initiative
baptisée le département est vous permet
d'échanger d'entretenir le lien avec les
élus municipaux et les associations des
communes on écoute pierre bettier il
était au micro de Gabriel bontier on
voit bien que on a des équipes
municipales très
concentré sur l'intérêt de leur
habitants et qui portent encore une fois
des jolis projets ce qu'il en ressort
c'est qu'ils apprécient que le
département soit échelon de proximité
qui coûte leur besoins qui essayent
d'apporter des réponses pas toujours on
n'est pas des magiciens et puis l'argent
public c'est rendre et donc ça doit être
distribué avec parcimonie je puis voir à
cette occasion que il y avait dans une
ville le 10 000 habitants des
équipements sportifs qu'on ne trouve pas
dans des villes bien plus importantes
donc c'est manifestement une commune qui
a
investi dans des équipements sportifs et
qui a même donné priorité à ces
équipements je comprends mieux pourquoi
il y a beaucoup de clubs ou de sélection
nationale qui viennent s'entraîner à
Croatie et on continue de parler de
politique avec la mobilisation de
certains élus contre l'extrême droite
effectivement Mathilde hier soir à
l'initiative du maire de Guyancourt un
rassemblement était organisé sur la
place de la mairie une trentaine de
personnes ont participé à ce
rassemblement objectif affirmer leur
position contre certains des événements
qui démontrent selon eux de monter de
l'extrême droite avec un message que
vous voulez faire passer François à
Morton le maire de la ville c'est Régine
ralech qui est allé recueillir son
sentiment c'est un message unitaire et
républicain voilà nous devons être
vigilants nous devons lutter nous devons
être de toutes les actions pour lutter
contre cette extrême droite
réémergente et lasse des mères qui ont
été effectivement qui ont subi des
pressions absolument intolérables qui
ont conduit d'ailleurs à la démission de
l'un d'eux à Saint-Brévin suite à un
projet courageux d'accueil de réfugiés
de centre d'accueil de demandeurs
d'asile mais aussi de plus proche que
nous effectivement on a eu des
manifestations parisiennes de
groupuscules d'extrême droite qui
s'affichent tranquillement dans la rue
avec des slogans et puis évidemment ce
qui s'est passé dans la commune voisine
de Saint-Cyr avec un concert nazi qui a
eu lieu dans cette commune dans la salle
Simone Veil lieu quand même avec un nom
hautement symbolique effectivement et ça
aurait pu arriver absolument partout
on va parler de tout autre chose à
présent Nicolas avec la remise des prix
du concours organisé par l'association
Yvelines environnement sensibiliser les
jeunes aux enjeux environnementaux et à
la biodiversité aussi tout cela à
travers des activités ludiques en classe
voilà l'objectif de l'association
Yvelines environnement à travers ce
concours il a débuté en janvier 2023 les
élèves âgés de 3 à 15 ans ont réalisé
des dessins et des maquettes autour du
thème nos amis les vers de terre les
gagnants ont été récompensés hier soir
et Julien Leroy est allé à la rencontre
de la présidente d'Yvelines
environnement et d'un éducateur qui a
accompagné les élèves dans ce projet si
vous voulez l'environnement on en parle
beaucoup mais est-ce qu'on sait
réellement de quoi il s'agit et nous
avons nous espérons que justement en
leur proposant chaque année un thème
concernant la biodiversité en
particulier
ça pouvait les aider pour l'avenir si
vous voulez pour mieux comprendre
combien il était important nos actions
sont importantes au quotidien et vous
avez vu effectivement en bas qui sont
exposés en bas et qui seront exposés à
Rambouillet aussi pendant l'été à partir
du mois de juillet ça nous a permis de
découvrir le thème des vers de terre on
a des bonnes surprises ce qu'on a des
fausses idées sur certains animaux
certains insectes et ça nous a permis de
découvrir en fait le monde
du vivant le monde des vers de terre et
les jeunes c'était une très bonne
expérience parce que ça nous a permis de
faire des liens aussi bien sur internet
que sur place pour aller sur pour quand
on était visité des sites en fait
plusieurs informations transports à
présent Nicolas et on commence par
Mantes-la-Jolie oui Mathilde le centre
opérationnel de bus de Mantes-la-Jolie
débute sa réhabilitation la capacité
d'accueil des bus va être élargie et une
conversion au gaz naturel véhicule GNV
va être effectué objectif rendre les bus
de la région du Gantois du Mantois
pardon du manteau de la région montoise
plus propre et la pose de la première
pierre s'est déroulée ce matin vous avez
sûrement dû voir les images à l'écran en
présence de Jean Castex qui est
président de du Groupe RATP du
conseiller régional Patrick Stéphanie
pour Île-de-France mobilité et du maire
de Mantes-la-Jolie Raphaël cogner et des
informations pratiques toujours dans les
transports Nicolas oui Mathilde si un
jour vous prenez un train sur la ligne N
Ouji Mathilde et bien
c'est possible et bien vous pourrez
connaître le taux de remplissage du
train
Île-de-France mobilité vient de déployer
une technologie sur les panneaux
d'affichage en gare pour connaître le
remplissage des différentes parties du
le train la couleur rouge signifie que
c'est rempli et qu'il sera difficile
d'avoir une place assise je sais que
vous y tenez Mathilde la couleur verte
indique une partie plus fluide là ça
sera plus simple pour trouver une place
assise et on garde le même code couleur
rouge vert pour parler bien de l'état de
déroutes durant votre week-end prolongé
attention pour ce jeudi matin de
l'Ascension Bison Futé voir rouge dans
le sens des départs il conseille
d'éviter l'autoroute A13 entre Paris et
quand de 9h à 17h et l'autoroute A10
entre Paris et tours de 7 heures à 15h
pour vendredi et samedi sévère dans les
deux sens de circulation en revanche
dimanche retour de week-end prolongé
bien évidemment Bison Futé voit noir
plusieurs conseils à vous donner évitez
l'autoroute A13 entre quand et Paris de
17h à 21h et même indication entre Paris
et Bordeaux sur la 10 entre 11h et
minuit petit rappel prenez vos
précautions sur la route faites
attention à ne pas éviter
risque sur la route et n'oubliez pas de
faire des pauses toutes les deux heures
merci beaucoup Nicolas dandry pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la à nous l'envoyer en utilisant le
hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale contre l'homophobie pour
en parler avec nous au Yann et Loïc
Navarro Chabrier un couple homo parental
vous vous êtes Unis en 2013 et je le
disais en début d'émission vous êtes
d'ailleurs le premier couple homosexuel
à vous êtes marié dans le département de
l'Ain suite à l'adoption de la loi pour
le mariage pour tous le mariage pour
tout ce qui fait d'ailleurs c'est dix
ans aujourd'hui selon le rapport de SOS
Homophobie de l'année 2022 les
agressions physiques homophobes sont en
inquiétante hausse l'association a
recensé 184 cas soit une agression
physique tous les deux jours c'est en
hausse de 28% par rapport à 2021 vous
même Yann et Loïc vous avez subi
plusieurs agressions la dernière remonte
au mois dernier vous avez retrouvé des
inscriptions homophobes et des menaces
de mort sur la porte et la boîte aux
lettres de votre appartement comment
réagissez-vous face à ces actes
la première réaction quand on l'a
découvert c'était beaucoup de colère
beaucoup de colère de tristesse
d'incompréhension puis après ça a fait
son petit peu le bonhomme de chemin et
puis maintenant c'est c'est même plus de
la colère enfin
c'est difficile à expliquer mais c'est
pas qu'on passe à côté mais on a plus
important à vivre aujourd'hui avec notre
fille que de voir à perdre de l'énergie
pour quelqu'un qui a même pas eu le
courage de venir nous voir et qui
préfère à la peinture marketing sur ma
porte plutôt que venir frapper et
discuter avec moi ou avec nous et
justement vous savez de qui peut
provenir ces messages non des doutes des
doutes comme vous l'avez dit au début
sur le voisinage parce que on est dans
une résidence et qui est pas sécurisé à
fond mais qui est sécurisé par un
premier portail avec un code une
deuxième entrée avec un code il faut
savoir qu'on monte au deuxième étage
chez moi il faut savoir que sur les
trois portes palières c'est celle là
donc on pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
sait qui connaît notre notre vie pour
savoir venir ici donc c'est pour ça
qu'on se doute que c'est dans le
voisinage
que vous avez ressenti de la colère
est-ce que plus procédure également
parlant vous êtes allé porter plainte
c'est pas la première fois qu'on est
qu'on est confronté à ça à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est depuis 2019
où on a eu deux trois mal toujours la
boîte aux lettres elle a un problème
avec les gens ma boîte aux lettres elle
doit être je sais pas agressive quand tu
passes devant du coup il s'acharne sur
elle donc les premières fois on a porté
plainte au commissariat de police de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et puis les fois
suivantes au niveau de la gendarmerie au
niveau du ministère de la Défense
comment on fait pour pour vivre au
quotidien comme vous le disais avec sans
cesse sa boîte aux lettres qui est
dégradée
on va nettoyer la boîte aux lettres on a
nettoyé la porte et on le fait avec on
n'a pas le choix on essaie de tourner la
chose de notre côté de positiver on a
pris une photo rigolote avec Rose devant
pour dire ben ouais c'est super tu as
écrit sur ma porte mais nous on est
toujours là on existe toujours on est
toujours heureux donc ça a pas marché ce
que tu as fait et on a énormément de
voisins et d'entourage qui nous ont
tellement soutenus que ce pauvre message
là c'était pas voilà c'est passé à côté
alors vous réagissez différemment
maintenant depuis que vous êtes parents
depuis que vous avez rose
c'était comme ça on fait avec encore une
fois et là quand c'était la porte on
avait rose et la voyait on a eu un peu
plus peur parce qu'en plus c'était pas
juste un mot écrit sur la boîte aux
lettres il y avait une menace de mort et
là ouais on a plus pensé à elle qu'à
nous pour le coup et d'ailleurs le
chemin pour pour avoir rose il a pas été
facile il a été un peu semé d'embûches
oui ça a duré 5 ans c'est c'est
compliqué parce que déjà c'est pas
autorisé en France donc déjà on rajoute
une première barrière et qui est quand
même conséquent et après on rajoute le
fait que ça soit frais à l'étranger que
on veut quelque chose d'éthique même si
ça peut paraître parfois bizarre de dire
ça mais nous on voulait quelque chose
d'éthique pas de commercial pas de voilà
et tout ça prend cinq ans pour qu'on
arrive enfin à trouver la bonne agence
le bon pays la bonne femme qui nous
accompagner dans cette belle histoire et
surtout c'est pas c'est la nature donc
nous on a mis deux ans avec des nombreux
échecs parce que c'est pas parce qu'on
va faire une GPA ou une PMA pour les
femmes que ça se passe tout de suite
parce qu'on a payé et qu'on a fait un
embryon que de transfert va marcher tout
de suite c'est la nature donc nous on a
eu cet échec avant d'arriver à avoir
rose d'ailleurs je le précise juste pour
noter les spectateurs qui viennent de
nous rejoindre vous avez rose en plateau
avec nous donc si vous entendez des
petits bruits vous inquiétez pas c'est
elle qui souhaitent aussi s'exprimer
de manière générale malgré du coup tout
ce dont on vient parler de ses
agressions répétées est-ce que vous avez
quand même le sentiment d'être accepté
au sein de la société aujourd'hui
tout s'améliore bien sûr qu'il y a
encore aujourd'hui des des différences
des des
en bas qu'il faut mener pour arriver au
mariage pour tous pour qu'on puisse
avoir le droit et ainsi de suite mais
ouais ça c'est c'est dix dernières
années ça c'est amélioré même au niveau
des forces de l'ordre ils ont été formés
pour pouvoir nous recevoir et recevoir
nos plaintes et nos problèmes et du coup
notre parole se libère plus en a moins
peur d'aller porter plainte à la même
peur d'en parler donc non il y a
beaucoup d'améliorations et comme le
disait mon mari tout à l'heure ça touche
des gens en particulier qui ont des
soucis plutôt qu'autre chose quoi on a
eu plus de messages de soutien que de
messages homophobes vraiment
donc on vient de voir des images pendant
que vous parliez de ce qui se passait il
y a 10 ans des manifestations la manif
pour tous une grosse contestation enfin
contestation
contre la loi qui autorise le mariage
pour tous les couples
comment vous voyez aujourd'hui quel est
le principal danger le principal risque
pour vous aujourd'hui quel risque vous
voyez pour vous au quotidien et quelles
sont les causes peut-être encore qui
font défendre aujourd'hui parce que
c'est on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout
peut-être
tout va bien les gens que je croise sont
sympas
sont normaux et en fait je vois pas de
risque ce que j'aimerais qui évolue en
fait c'est que c'est qu'on gagne
l'indifférence c'est à dire que comme
n'importe quel couple dans la totale
indifférence je puisse tenir la main à
mon mari sans que on est des regards
voir ma fille aller faire je sais pas
les courses sans avoir des voilà qu'on
passe pour des gens dans une totale
indifférence c'est ça que le point
existe encore ce que vous dites ça
existe
encore des regards aujourd'hui
après c'est notre notre génération à
nous on a du mal à un public on va
réfléchir à deux fois avant d'avoir des
gestes que n'importe quel autre couple
aurait pu avoir comme un bisou quand on
vient de se rencontrer au boulot sur
Paris ou quand on a cherché la quelque
chose comme ça on va y réfléchir demain
il faudrait que les gens et les futurs
générations n'est pas à se poser cette
question là et que ça devienne naturel
quoi alors dans l'actualité dernièrement
des
jours en Ligue 1 ont fait polémique des
footballeurs de Toulouse et de Nantes
notamment ont refusé de porter un
maillot arc-en-ciel dans le cadre de
cette journée internationale contre
l'homophobie comment réagissez-vous face
à ces refus
ant
parce qu'on est pas très fous
j'ai envie de dire ils font ce qu'ils
veulent c'est dommage parce qu'ils ont
une image ils ont une visibilité mais
s'il souhaitait pas le faire ils avaient
le droit
ça c'est mon point de vue après on a pas
le même on est pas d'accord
l'homophobie c'est pas une opinion c'est
un délit donc de pas vouloir le porter
je le comprends il avait pas envie parce
qu'il aime pas les couleurs il y a aucun
souci par contre si il se cache derrière
quelque chose une religion un avis ou un
truc c'est plus c'est plus pareil quoi
et
c'est pas le c'est pas la journée pour
laquelle il faut qu'il soit contre ou
quoi que ce soit il faut qu'il y ait un
débat il faut qu'il y ait des
discussions il faut pas s'arrêter à une
journée c'est les 364 autres journées
qui sont importantes et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aller dans la discussion dans
l'éducation dans le partage et c'est
super important qu'on le fasse dans le
foot parce que le foot
nous on n'aime pas mais il y a plein de
millions de gens qui adorent et je pense
que oui ils ont une image à faire passer
et là je pense qu'ils ont pas fait
passer la bonne image tant pis pour eux
ils ont pas ils ont pas joué je crois
c'est quel joueur je crois qu'ils ont
pas joué c'est eux qui ont loupé un
match qui aurait dû être sympa et puis
voilà si ce mec des barrières tout seul
tant pis pour eux quoi
ils ont oublié une occasion de jouer et
de s'éclater dans leur sport quoi et
bien merci beaucoup
[Musique]
Chabrier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et puis d'avoir témoigner sur
ce plateau direction l'aérodrome de
Toussus-le-Noble à présent ils étaient
une centaine à manifester samedi dernier
pour faire diminuer le trafic aérien il
souhaitait notamment la mise en place
d'indicateurs pour pouvoir mesurer la
baisse des niveaux sonores le reportage
de Julien Leroy
un concert de klaxon pour protester
contre des bourdonnements de turbine une
centaine d’habitants s'étaient donnés
rendez-vous aux abords de l'aérodrome de
Toussus-le-Noble ce samedi 13 mai à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
de sensibilisation au bruit les
riverains étaient venus dénoncer
l'absence de mesure concrètes sur les
nuisances sonores causées par les
aérones il y a des jours où ça devient
assez infernal parce que ça n'arrête pas
c'est par vague
et les avions des fils les uns derrière
les autres depuis 2011 les habitants
impactés des communes limitrophes se
sont rassemblés au sein du collectif
alliance associative l'an passé environ
119.000 mouvements d'aéronefs ont été
enregistrés à l'aérodrome de
Toussus-le-Noble aujourd'hui
c'est notre light motif c'est réduction
du trafic et surtout réduction du trafic
des avions bruyants et mis en place
d'indicateurs qui vont permettre
effectivement de mesurer cette baisse de
nuisance c'était les pilotes volat à
l'aérodrome depuis 3 ans selon lui des
efforts ont été faits pour minimiser la
pollution sonore il demande aux
habitants de la patience en attendant le
renouvellement progressif de la flotte
faire des avions plus silencieux je
pense que toute leur revendications il
faut les écouter il faut les entendre en
effet on est sur des anciennes machines
qui parfois font un petit peu de bruit
pour autant on a pas mal de contraintes
sur l'aérodrome notamment pour des
circuits à respecter pour ne pas gêner
ou minimiser de la gêne envers les
riverains ça prend du temps de changer
un sport ça prend du temps de changer
des technologies et que c'est en marche
ça va dans le bon sens et même si ça va
pas la vitesse qu'il le souhaiterait ce
qui est peut-être enable
bah ça avance et c'est quand même
positif le collectif envisage d'autres
mobilisations si au canal corps n’est
trouvé avec ces deux pistes le site de
tous sur le noble et le quatrième
aérodrome d'aviation d'affaires et de
loisirs en France
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
une autre journaliste de la rédaction de
tv78 Régine rage bonsoir bonsoir alors
comme chaque mercredi vous nous
présentez votre chronique et du Talk ce
soir vous nous parlez de deux écoles qui
verront bientôt le jour dans les
Yvelines l'une à Mantes-la-Jolie et
l'autre à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines tout
à fait Mathilde tout à fait et cette
école s'est liagée donc l'Institut des
arts de la gestion c'est une école qui
propose des formations autour du
management d'entreprise plusieurs un
niveau de diplôme sont proposés il y a
un BTS il y a aussi des Bachelor et des
masters et d'ailleurs on retrouve
notamment le BTS MCO donc management
commercial opérationnel il y a le
Bachelor Marketing Digital et
communication ou encore le master
ingénieur d'affaires alors les diplômes
délivrés sont reconnus par l'État et
accessible en formation initiale où on
apprentissage mais ce qui est
intéressant notamment c'est que cette
école elle a été fondée par deux
yvelinois donc Walid youfi et Arsène
paphyla alors en école elle est basée à
Clichy elle a ouvert ses portes il y a
un peu plus d'un an et ils ont justement
accueilli 80 élèves cette année et face
au succès de cette école les deux
associés prévoient en ouvrir quatre
autres dont une à 50 ans Yvelines et une
à Nantes la jolie alors qu'est-ce qu'il
fait la particularité de cette école
régime alors justement cette école ce
qui est intéressant également c'est
qu'elle applique la politique de
l'égalité des chances elle favorise la
diversité et l'inclusion les prix sont
également attractifs et pour entrer dans
l'école il n'y a pas de critères
spécifiques mis à part bien évidemment
le niveau bac il faut passer par des
entretiens ou justement une équipe
pédagogique se charge de de d'évaluer en
fait les points forts et les points
faibles du candidat afin d'adapter au
mieux l'enseignement à l'élève la
moyenne d'âge également si on en parle
elle est assez basse elle se situe aux
alentours de 28 ans et donc du coup tout
ce qui est autour des méthodes employées
pour communiquer ou pour
partager justement les équipes ils sont
assez dans l'air du temps puisque ils
utilisent énormément les téléphones
portables et très peu les mails
puisqu'ils ont peur justement de pas
avoir de retour et puis comme on a
peut-être pu également le voir à l'écran
il y a des événements avec des remises
de prix donc tout se fait de manière
assez ludique et justement pour en
parler donc j'ai rencontré l'un des
fondateurs de l'école Walid you see et
un étudiant également aux cannes obuc je
vous propose les écouter donc on sait ce
que c'est on sait c'est quoi être
étudiant c'est quoi un étudiant
voilà en fait on est les seuls
on est les seuls les directeurs ou
directrices d'école en général ils ont
la cinquantaine ils ont des cursus qui
ont rien à voir avec ce qui propose à
leurs étudiants moi j'ai des amis j'ai
de la famille qui ont fait des BTS qui
ont fait des Bachelor qui ont fait des
masters donc on est on est sensible à
ces sujets là dans l'ensemble en tout
cas les équipes sont jeunes très à
l'écoute et on a des professeurs qui ont
beaucoup de savoir beaucoup de savoir et
c'est ce qui m'a apporté le plus en tout
cas moi sur mon expérience
c'est ce qui m'a apporté le plus le
contact avec les professeurs ce qu'on
partage ensemble le fait de pouvoir
communiquer avec eux n'importe quand par
SMS alors l'accessibilité voilà alors je
le disais justement tout à l'heure
l'école semble afficher deux très bons
résultats et l'objectif l'an prochain
c'est justement d'accueillir 300
étudiants et ils sont d'ailleurs sur la
bonne route puisque sur parcoursup il y
a plus de 600 étudiants qui ont déjà
indiqué l'iagées parmi leurs vœux merci
beaucoup Régine rallès et donc on suivra
avec attention l'ouverture de ces deux
nouvelles écoles dans les Yvelines
est-ce que vous savez la date ou l'année
de la rupture les deux prochaines écoles
sont prévues pour l'année 2024 donc ça
va arriver très rapidement donc ce sera
à suivre en 2024 un peu de sport à
présent il a débuté le basket dans les
Yvelines et s'apprête à découvrir le
prestigieux championnat de NBA aux
États-Unis Victor one bagnat connaît
désormais sa probable future destination
pour la saison la semaine prochaine la
loterie de la draft a dévoilé l'équipe
qui aura le premier choix de recrutement
le 22 juin prochain et qui devrait donc
sauf grande surprise enrôler le jeune
basketteur français l'interview de
Grégory canalet
tous ces jouets la nuit dernière dans la
nuit du 16 au 17 mai aux alentours de C2
heures du matin à la loterie de la draft
NBA le prestigieux championnat de basket
nord-américain a livré son verdict les
Spurs de San Antonio décroche le premier
choix pour sélectionner un jeûne sport
du basket en vue de la saison prochaine
la franchise texane devrait donc
recruter le 22 juin prochain jour de la
draft 2023 livlinois Victor Wayne bagnat
premier une place de numéro 1 on
rappelle que le joueur français a foulé
ses premiers parquets dans les Yvelines
au club de l'Entente Le Chesnay
Versailles on débriefe tout de suite
cette actualité avec Mike Mokongo
bonjour Mike bonjour basketteur
international de la République
centrafricaine
intéressant joueur de laisser tras vous
êtes d'ailleurs à habitant des Yvelines
et vous comptez une longue carrière
derrière vous dans le basket un club
pour citer un par lequel vous êtes passé
celui de Monaco qui a une actualité
européenne en ce moment et vous êtes
aussi quelque part le consultant de
basket de TV 70 qui nous intervenez très
régulièrement dans l'émission si on
parle espagnol pour le grand public de
voir Victor web benyama rejoindre très
probablement les sports ça évoque tout
de suite le nom de Tony Parker la
légende du basket français qui a gagné
avec l'équipe texane quatre titres de
NBA il y a évolué pendant près de 20 ans
Boris dieux aussi a joué du côté des
Spurs entre 2011 et 2016 c'était la
meilleure destination la destination
idyllique pour Victor web benjama de
rejoindre l'espace tout d'abord waouh un
père une performance historique pour
Victor et toute sa famille et notamment
aussi le basket français et on est
vraiment ravis de le voir là parce que
voilà quand on parle tout de suite de
son antonosport s'enfonce à un cocher
légendaire qui est Greg Popovic un
entraîneur a vraiment qui a révolutionné
le basketball avec des garçons comme
voilà team
notamment Tony Parker aussi 2127 matchs
de NBA coacher par par Greg Popovic
exactement pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
voilà c'est un des meilleurs coachs au
monde avec Phil Jackson et puis voilà
son antonosport c'est une culture une
identité de basketball un savoir-faire
un environnement qui est sain c'est
vraiment tout ce qu'on pouvait lui
souhaiter et puis aussi il a un double
culture il connaît bien les joueurs
français en général donc voilà
franchement super super content pour eux
même si c'est une franchise récemment
qui qui réalise des saisons qui sont
vraiment donci en la vue encore cette
année une saison qui est extrêmement
difficile pour eux je le rappelle s'ils
étaient dans cette loterie de la draft
et s'ils sont arrivés numéro 1 c'est
parce qu'ils ont terminé dans le bas du
classement NBA ils sont pas qualifiés en
playoff bien sûr tout à fait il faisait
partie des trois équipes qui avaient 14%
de chance même si on sait que des fois
il peut avoir des scénarios incroyables
parce qu'elle a loterie c'est vraiment
un ping-pong c'est mais voilà on est
super ravis pour pour son Antonio il y a
un projet qui va être construit autour
de Victor justement il y a des garçons
qui sont aussi intéressant dans cette
équipe là Kindle Johnson délivacel
Jeremy Sochaux voilà ils ont des jeunes
qui sont intéressants après il va
falloir voir est-ce que Popovic va
continuer ou pas il y a aussi des
suspicions un petit peu autour de ça
mais voilà moi je pense qu'il va il va
continuer à coacher jusqu'à 90 ans étant
donné que Victor il sera là donc ça sera
sympa ouais plus de 70 ans pour Greg
popovitch qui a quand même aussi un qui
est connu pour avoir une capacité à
faire progresser les joueurs en NBA
d'ailleurs on peut citer aussi deux noms
qui sont passés du côté des sports
puisque les sports savaient déjà eu le
choix numéro 1 de la draft en 87 et en
97 il y avait eu David Robinson et Tim
Duncan deux grands champions tous les
deux titrés en NBA qui ont été tous les
deux MVP qui figurent aujourd'hui au
Hall of Fame ça ne dure que des bonnes
choses pour Victor et Mania mala vous
vous le dites en plus a priori au vu des
récentes prestations de des Spurs il va
être placé au centre du projet non
forcément c'est lui le franchias player
comme ils le disent aux États-Unis et le
projet va être pensé autour de lui ils
vont construire autour de lui et voilà à
propos vite il est connu justement pour
son sa capacité à développer les joueurs
les rendre meilleur on a vu un garçon
comme quoi elle honneur qui a joué un
NBA qui a commencé par les Spurs où
personne ne le pensait à ce niveau-là et
et donc voilà moi je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il fallait pour
lui et puis il a un grand frère Tony
Parker qui connaît bien la région qui
connaît le coin donc il sera aussi lui
donner des bons conseils et je tiens
aussi à féliciter justement l'agence
comme sport parce que ils ont fait un
très bon boulot je trouve qu'ils ont une
intelligence à penser ce projet là un
petit peu comme à l'image de cette année
avec les métropolitains 92 autour de lui
un environnement sain pour que lui
justement il puisse bien travailler les
mettre 92 dans le club dans lequel il a
évolué cette saison dans lequel il
évolue toujours il y a des playoffs qui
s'ouvrent aussi pour ce club des Metz 92
19 ans le monde a ses pieds on a parlé
souvent de ces dimensions incroyables
ces deux mètres 21 pour Victor web
benyama et ce qu'il a les clés pour
réussir est-ce que c'est pas une
montagne trop grande pour lui c'était
NBA tout d'abord on parle là d'un joueur
quand même
hyper hyper hyper suivi déjà alors qu'il
est même pas encore un NBA et on part là
d'un garçon qui a un potentiel
incroyable entre l'allerge de la
technique et la taille et on sait que
voilà c'est un garçon qui a des
attributs de de joueurs extérieurs il
est vite
il est délié dribble bien il est capable
de tirer il a vraiment tout pour lui au
fait ça ça fait de lui un basketteur
vraiment hybride et on le compare
beaucoup à des garçons comme Kevin
Durant Dirk nowitzky voilà moi je pense
que il faut que toutes les planètes
soient alignées pour lui d'ailleurs là
il est dans une bonne franchise qu'il
est son antonosport maintenant il faut
construire autour de lui il faut lui
donner l'opportunité de continuer à
performer aussi à le facteur blessure
qui est aussi important on sait que ça
pue l'handicapé ces dernières années un
peu moins cette saison où il a eu un peu
plus de continuité exactement où c'était
une des questions cette année mais cette
année il fait plus de 50 matchs et donc
je pense qu'il a répondu aussi à ça d'où
le projet qui était justement qui puisse
faire un match par semaine et lui
permettre justement de préparer son
corps qu'est-ce que il doit travailler à
votre avis sur quels aspects il doit
travailler pour réussir cette nouvelle
étape dans sa carrière
alors tout d'abord ça va être
intéressant de voir comment ils vont le
faire jouer parce que Victor c'est un
poste 4 plutôt un poste 4 qui tire de
l'extérieur qui peut aussi jouer au dos
au panier qui peut aller face au panier
donc ça serait important pour lui de
prendre un petit peu de masse parce que
de temps en temps je pense que dans le
NBA moderne il va des fois passer poste
5 ensuite il y a aussi son tir extérieur
à 3 points qui doit perfectionner parce
que cette année tu iras 30 % la ligne
RnB elle est beaucoup plus longue cette
mètres 23 c'est un garçon qui doit aussi
progresser dans dans sa capacité à
prendre les bonnes décisions donc voilà
et puis après
c'est difficile à dire quand tu fais une
saison aussi incroyable comme il fait
mais je pense que voilà il a tout pour
lui pour réaliser une belle saison on
lui souhaite en tout cas de pleine
réussite dans cette nouvelle étape de la
NBA la draft c'est le 22 juin prochain
normalement sauf grande surprise donc
Victor HUG benjama qui devrait rejoindre
les Spurs de San Antonio ça saison n'est
pas terminée parce que je le disais il y
a les playoffs avec les mètres 92 qui
seront opposés à Cholet pour les
playoffs de cette
pro A2 basket merci beaucoup Mike
d'avoir parlé de cette actualité avec
moi merci merci beaucoup à vous aussi et
j'ai bien envie de finir sur une
dernière chose allez-y je voudrais
encore féliciter mon ami à laver qui
fait partie des hommes importants au
club de métropolitain ce qui en fait un
bon boulot autour de Victor féliciter
aussi Bouna Ndiaye qui est son agent et
aussi et aussi voilà tout le basket
français doit se réjouir devant un
garçon à ce niveau là on doit lui donner
toutes les capacités et les moyens de
pouvoir y arriver et franchement on est
vraiment fiers j'espère que la région
c'est super fière de ça on devenir plus
longuement sur cette actualité dans la
prochaine émission si on parlait sport
sur TV 78
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure d'ouvrir une large
page cinéma dans votre recette 8 le 76e
Festival de Cannes c'est ouvert hier la
grande fête du cinéma se déroule
jusqu'au 27 mai à cette occasion TV 78
grâce à Radio sensation vous emmène sur
la Croisette on retrouve sur place
Corentin Alonso qui a rencontré
Marie-Ange Casalta la journaliste né à
saint-germain-en-lay a réalisé son tout
premier film un court-métrage tourné
dans les Yvelines regardez le Festival
de Cannes c'est aussi l'occasion pour
certains réalisateurs de montrer leur
tout premier film cette année Marie-Ange
Casalta est venue présenter son premier
court-métrage ça s'appelle The Last
diner un film avec notamment
François-Xavier Demaison c'est
l'histoire de quatre potes quatre amis
qui qui quittent New York Manhattan pour
passer un petit week-end à la campagne
dans une zone où il y a pas de réseau
ils sont vraiment isolés du monde et
durant une partie de Scrabble ils font
un pari sur l'existence d'un mot et
zopia est-ce que ça existe vraiment et
Paris 500 dollars et celui certains que
ça n'existe pas décident de sortir je
sais ce qu'il est du réseau pour
chercher sur google si le mot existe
vraiment et là qu'est-ce qu'il apprend
il apprend que c'est la fin du monde en
20 minutes il va y avoir une attaque
nucléaire sur toute la côte est des
États-Unis et retourne dans la maison et
est-ce que je leur dis où est-ce que je
lui dis je leur dis pas voilà j'ai 20
minutes avec mes meilleures amies est-ce
que je leur dis ça pose une vraie
question existentielle et pour tourner
ce film dont l'action se passe aux
États-Unis dans le Connecticut
Marie-Ange Casalta a trouvé l'endroit
parfait et il se trouve dans les
Yvelines pour tourner ce film on s'est
vraiment pris la tête sur le lieu du
décor vraiment on a visité des tonnes de
maison il fallait que ça fasse américain
qu'on y croit vraiment qu'on soit dans
le Connecticut ok il fallait aussi qu'on
ait aucune habitation autour puisqu'ils
sont coupés du monde ils sont au milieu
de nulle part c'était pas facile
honnêtement il fallait pas que ce soit
pas trop loin de Paris parce que Londres
François-Xavier tous les comédiens on
voulait pas les faire voyager depuis
toute l'équipe donc on a trouvé cette
maison incroyable qui se trouve à marée
Marly qui s'appelle la canopée c'est en
fait c'est une sorte de gîte où ils font
beaucoup de yoga beaucoup de choses
comme ça c'est du monde c'est dans la
forêt c'est un lieu vraiment magique
avec une âme vraiment et la propriétaire
était formidable et nous a dit ça me
fait tellement plaisir que vous tourniez
ce film ici je veux que ce lieu vive qui
vive plein d'expériences différentes
donc on était tous très heureux on a
tourné là sur deux jours au mois de
janvier une grosse partie du film ce
tourne à l'extérieur se passe à
l'extérieur on a eu extrêmement
franchement ce que j'ai eu le plus froid
de toute ma vie on a tous dit qu'on
avait mis une semaine à ne plus avoir
froid après
oh là là le froid en pleine forêt au
mois de janvier mais tout le monde a été
incroyable on avait des chaufferettes
partout et
c'était l'endroit idéal puisque tu
regardes le film et tu te dis vraiment
les gens ne peuvent pas croire qu'on
n'était pas aux enfants des connectiques
donc l'endroit était parfait
the last diner un film de Marie-Ange
Casalta que les festivaliers pourront
découvrir cette année à Cannes le 24 mai
au Short Film Corner
et nous avons été rejoints par Céline
Charles un plateau bonsoir Céline
bonsoir dans quelques instants vous
allez nous présenter les films à ne pas
manquer cette semaine au cinéma mais
avant je vous en parlais en début
d'émission un jeune yvelinois originaire
de Sartrouville va bientôt monter les
marches du festival de Cannes Youssef 18
ans a participé au projet moteur il
s'agit d'un concours de films ouverts
aux jeunes de 14 à 22 ans le défi faire
le portrait d'une personne qui les
inspire en une minute trente l'objectif
est également de donner confiance aux
jeunes
issus de tout milieu dans une démarche
inclusive Youssef pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé de vous lancer dans ce
projet moteur
ça me plaît et moi bah ça fait longtemps
que j'ai voulu être dans le cinéma au
début ça a pas marché comme je vous l'ai
dit ensuite on m'a proposé un concours
et j'ai saisi l'occasion et j'ai voulu
participer à payer alors comment ça
c'est fait comment est-ce qu'on vous a
proposé le concours comment est-ce que
vous êtes tombé dessus bah je ne
connaissance qui m'a qui savais que bah
je vais parler de ça du coup qui savais
que je voulais être dans le cinéma et
bah il a fait plusieurs courts métrages
qui bah ont fonctionnait du coup bah il
m'a proposé de faire un court-métrage je
l'ai je l'ai fait et ça fait et vous
aviez déjà fait des des petits films des
petites vidéos par avance j'en ai pas
fait pour un concours j'en ai fait la
vie quotidienne mais pour un concours
c'est la première fois que je fais un
court métrage
pour le cinéma bon regardant des films
ça me plaît les films j'aime trop les
films et bah tout ce qui est comique
action et
voilà moi je suis dans ça dans le sport
aussi c'est quoi votre film préféré film
préféré c'est surtout les films comiques
moi je suis plus dans les films comiques
et dans les films d'action et du coup
plus tard vous avez envie de faire un
métier dans dans l'univers du cinéma ce
serait quoi plutôt du coup réalisateur
scénariste vous avez déjà une idée de
réalisateur mais aussi acteur ça
j'aimerais bien faire acteur en premier
et si bah j'ai pas l'occasion
j'essayerai réalisateur ça vous fait
rêver
et donc si vous devez donner un conseil
un jeune qui n'oserait pas participer au
projet moteur vous lui donne quoi comme
conseil
et de toujours essayer de saisir les
moindres occasions et ça peut
fonctionner la preuve et donc pour ce
concours vous avez choisi de parler de
Martin Luther King pourquoi cette
personnalité pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
vous inspire le sujet bah c'est le sujet
c'est quelque chose qui vous inspire et
moi j'habite dans un endroit où la rue
c'est Martin Luther King du coup bah
j'ai choisi Martin Luther King parce que
il m'inspire parce qu'il a fait des
grandes choses un combat de jeu pour les
personnes de couleur et ça ça m'a
beaucoup inspiré et j'ai voulu faire sur
Martin Luther King
d'en parler davantage je vous propose
justement de regarder ce mini film
réalisé par Youssef sur Martin Luther
King
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et moi avocats
vraiment que toi tu vas être mère toi
journaliste et toi vocal
Simon della fiche
c'est un président
on va se poser on va faire un match
écoutez le pas la journée portes
ouvertes pour pas qu'on a des origines
d'immigré et combien doit de cités
défavorisées qu'on va pas réussir
regarde Martin Luther King mes frérot tu
t'appelles
aider les gens il a formé il était
avocat il est des gens et il était
surtout mer donc ça a l'air ça s'appelle
le politique et c'est le parking de la
rue ils sont en faire trois chacun
d'entre nous prend en faire un
[Musique]
alors du coup c'est avec vos amis que
vous avez tourné ce film avec mes amis
et du coup ça se passe à Sartrouville
dans le quartier où vous avez grandi
dans le quartier qui est la cité des
Indes on s'est retrouvé et ben j'ai fait
ça avec mes amis bah dans la rue Martin
mittering
c'est pour ça que voilà
vous avez créé le scénario
tout à l'heure comme je vous ai dit j'ai
lâché un petit peu la faire parce que ça
marchait pas et du coup bah là je me
suis dit pourquoi pas faire un scénario
ou je lâche l'affaire et je crois pas
aux autres et bah pour montrer comme
quoi j'ai réussi et au final faut pas
lâcher l'affaire c'est c'est ce message
là que vous avez voulu faire passer dans
cette vidéo
et donc selon vous qu'est-ce qui a fait
la différence au niveau du jury du jury
d'ailleurs présidé par oxpo Puccino et
d'autres acteurs culturels
institutionnels engagés pour les jeunes
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
auprès du jury selon vous selon moi je
pense que j'ai été plus à l'aise et que
je savais un peu ce que je faisais et
que je voulais réussir et que je voulais
vraiment y participer à ce concours et
alors ce 25 mai la semaine prochaine
vous avez rendez-vous avec les célèbres
marche du Festival de Cannes vous savez
déjà comment ça va se passer quel est le
programme sur place vous allez être
accompagné on va être accompagné je sais
qu'on va aller pour monter les marches
et qu'on va rencontrer des personnes un
peu plus professionnelle qui connaissent
un peu plus et pourquoi pas y apprendre
davantage et
il y aura nos têtes et nos visages
exposés à la gare de Cannes vous espérez
aussi rencontrer des stars du cinéma
particulier
je sais que des films au marché
surtout ceux qui sont dans l'action et
qui sont marrants c'est des acteurs qui
vous inspirent aussi aujourd'hui
pourquoi
famille vos amis quand vous avez appris
que vous avez été sélectionné bah ils
étaient heureux c'était content ils ont
vu que bah j'avais lâché l'affaire et
que j'ai repris et ben j'étais heureux
pour moi aussi du coup j'étais heureux
même si faut pas lâcher pour la
prochaine et pour la suite
et vous avez d'autres projets peut-être
dans le cinéma à venir
peut-être de plus en plus grand au
niveau du cinéma et pourquoi pas faire
comme ce que j'aime bien comme Marseille
alors justement cet hôtel l'aventure
continue puisque vous allez pouvoir
suivre des ateliers sur sur du slam du
théâtre et de l'éloquence vous
l'attendez avec impatience
je veux tout ce qui est possible de
faire pour aller plus loin je veux le
faire c'est je veux aller sur ce sur ce
chemin vous avez une préférence parmi le
théâtre le cinéma le slam le cinéma
et bien merci beaucoup Youssef d'avoir
répondu à nos questions on vous souhaite
un Nicolas vous avez une dernière
question non j'ai cru on vous souhaite
un bon festival de Cannes et donc si
vous aussi vous êtes intéressé par le
projet moteur vous retrouverez toutes
les informations sur le site Internet
qui s'affiche juste en dessous en bas de
votre écran pour pouvoir participer
l'année prochaine et on poursuit cette
page cinéma avec vous Céline vous nous
avez fait une petite sélection des films
à ne pas manquer cette semaine dans les
salles obscures et on commence votre
sélection avec le très attendu Fast and
Furious 10 oui bien sûr Mathilde la saga
remet le couvert pour un nouvel opus
réaliser par le Français Louis le
terrier dans ce dixième épisode d'homme
le personnage emblématique interprété
par Vin Diesel revient toujours plus
fort entouré de sa femme et de son fils
de 8 ans alors pour comprendre
l'intrigue de ce film il faut se
replonger dans Fast and Furious five
sortie en 2011 le duo d'homme et Brian
mettait un terme aux agissements d'un
cartel brésilien sévissant à Rio en
éliminant leur leader Hernan Reyes
disant après c'est son fils dans tes
Reyes qui revient pour se venger il est
incarné par l'acteur Jason Momoa
regardez c'est ça le problème d'avoir
une famille nombreuse lesquels
tu vas choisir de sauver
[Musique]
c'est parti
tu sais toujours conduire
et au-delà du casting d'acteur le
casting automobile est toujours le
premier choix les fans de voiture seront
servis avec des cours se poursuites à
non plus finir en Alfa Romeo Lamborghini
Mustang et la saga passe aussi au vert
ils ont cette année une voiture 100%
électrique avec la DeLorean alpha 5 et
en cette Journée internationale de lutte
contre l'homophobie le film sublime de
Mariano biasin tombe à point nommer
Céline et oui mais c'est un film qui ne
se veut justement qui ne veut pas
s'attarder sur les débats ou le
militantisme il s'attache seulement à
raconter l'histoire des personnages et à
traduire leurs émotions manuelles à 16
ans c'est un adolescent plutôt classique
il sort avec ses copains joue de la base
dans un groupe de rock traîne avec ça
petite amie mais c'est avec son meilleur
ami Felipe que les choses se compliquent
amis depuis toujours les deux garçons
ont grandi ensemble ils sont très
proches mais à l'aube de l'âge adulte ce
lien prend peu à peu une tournure
différente lorsque manuel éprouve des
sentiments nouveaux pour faire l'IP un
film simple et tout en douceur sur la
naissance des des premiers et moi et des
questionnements adolescents et on
termine votre sélection Céline avec
l'arbre aveu c'est un film d'animation
oui ce sera pour les petits mais aussi
pour les grands alors des animaux vivent
en harmonie dans une cité sanctuaire
protégée par un arbre aveuré il est ce
qui les maintient hors du danger du
monde extérieur mais qui rit un opossum
avec une grande soif d'aventure va
mettre en péril cet équilibre elle va
alors devoir se rattraper et se lancer
dans une quête avec sa soeur Petra pour
sauver la cité de l'extinction un film
avec une belle morale sur l'entraide et
les liens familiaux merci beaucoup
Céline Charles alors comme d'habitude
petit tour de plateau est-ce que vous
avez des préférences parmi votre
sélection j'aurais peut-être voir Fast
and Furious quand même c'est un
classique voilà
[Rires]
toujours dans l'univers du cinéma on
découvre un portrait après à présent le
lycée de Saint-Exupéry à Mantes-la-Jolie
a accueilli jeudi dernier Nelly Quétier
monteuse depuis plus de 40 ans elle a
échangé sur son métier avec les élèves
le reportage de vous c'est ninja elle
est de ceux qui travaillent dans l'ombre
Nelly Quétier fait partie des petites
mains qui participent à la confection
d'un film monteuse de cinéma depuis de
nombreuses années elle a remporté le
César 2022 du meilleur montage pour le
film Annette de Léo karax et s'est
accompagné de la fameuse statuette
qu'elle est revenue dans son ancien
lycée à Mantes-la-Jolie face à la
nouvelle génération elle a mis en
lumière ce métier encore assez méconnu
j'ai essayé de trouver des photos j'ai
très peu de photos de moi dans une salle
de montage c'est quelque chose qu'on
confirme pas c'est pas c'est quelque
chose on comprend pas en photo c'est
c'est même prendre des photos de sol de
montage on sait jamais où se mette etc
c'est et puis c'est un moment intime le
montage c'est un moment intime on est on
est trois dans une salle de montage et
un réalisateur la matière et le monteur
vraiment bien dans le montage c'est avec
chaque réalisateur avec qui vous
travaillez c'est différent chaque fois
il faut s'adapter même si maintenant par
Internet on sait un peu plus de choses
qu'à mon époque c'est quand même un
métier assez mystérieux très c'est très
très difficile d'en parler de ce métier
c'est ça ça relève de beaucoup de choses
et peu de gens savent à quoi ça consiste
Nelly a été invité dans le cadre d'un
César à l'école un dispositif éducatif
et artistique créé par l'association un
artiste à l'école en collaboration avec
l'Académie des Césars leur mission
rendre accessible la culture aux jeunes
en faisant revenir des artistes
césarisés dans leur ancien établissement
scolaire on travaille avec les
professeurs qui sont inscrits on fournit
un dossier pédagogique et quelques
ressources autour de l'intervenant le
jour J on revient on revisite un peu
l'établissement pour ramener les
souvenirs à l'intervenant et puis il y a
après c'est un échange basé sur les
questions des élèves le but c'est qu'il
soit vraiment plutôt dans l'action
de la pellicule ou numérique vous l'avez
pris comment vous c'était dur ou facile
des moments de transmission qui
éveillent la curiosité des élèves
projet pendant des heures et des heures
Monster c'est incroyable ça renforce un
peu le lien parce que on se dit c'est
des millions un peu on peut pas y aller
accéder tout ça alors que là si ils
viennent jusqu'ici bah c'est
vrai
des trucs comme ça c'est intéressant et
surtout de faire savoir que par exemple
les quetsches elle était là
Saint-Exupéry mais on peut dire que bah
peut-être ça peut nous arriver à nous et
ça nous donne un peu une confiance près
de 17000 élèves partout en France ont pu
bénéficier de ce dispositif depuis sa
création en 2012 de quoi susciter
plusieurs vocations
oklm est-ce que ça vous dit quelque
chose il s'agit de la nouvelle web série
de cet épisode réalisé par les élèves du
collège Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet
elle est sortie après plusieurs mois de
tournage au total 10 élèves ont
travaillé sur le projet avec leur
professeur et le réalisateur yvelinois
Benjamin pallier à la fois technicien et
acteurs ils ont pu découvrir les
différents métiers du cinéma en écoute
Benjamin pallier au micro de Céline
Charles
quelques années ont passé les visages
ont changé mais l'énergie est restée la
même Martin Manon et Idris vous ouvre
les portes de leur kebab en toute
tranquillité
[Musique]
je suis Benjamin pallier je suis
réalisateur je suis éducateur en média
au collège Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet
et cette année avec mes élèves de
l'atelier cinéma nous avons réalisé une
série qui s'appelle au calme au KLM qui
se déroule en 7 épisodes cet épisode de
5 6 minutes et qui sont diffusés
prochainement alors cette série elle
raconte l'histoire de deux jeunes
adolescents donc un garçon et une fille
Nathan et Nola qui se rendent tous les
jours au kebab pour prendre le repas et
qui ont une certaine relation avec le
gérant du kebab ou la gérante et qui
demande des conseils donc le but c'est à
la fois pédagogique et artistique
artistique puisque les élèves de mon
atelier cinéma font à la fois derrière
la caméra et devant la caméra et
pédagogique puisque la série chaque
épisode de la série aborde un sujet
différent lié à l'adolescence donc par
exemple la première épisode c'est sur le
stress de la rentrée le deuxième sur le
téléphone portable il y a aussi des
épisodes sur le divorce sur le
harcèlement scolaire enfin on essaye de
traiter différents sujets de
l'adolescence à travers cette série mais
toujours avec une certaine légèreté
voilà le but c'est de donner des
conseils aux jeunes qui nous regardent
mais toujours avec un esprit comique
donc cette série a été réalisée donc
avec 10 adolescents que j'ai dans mon
atelier cinéma la plupart des scènes ont
été tournées au collège Sainte-Thérèse
de Rambouillet il y a des scènes qui ont
été tournées dans le pari du Château de
Rambouillet ou or sur la petite place
juste devant le collège
et si vous êtes intéressé la web-série
au kLM est à retrouver sur notre chaîne
le samedi à 14h30 et 22h30 et également
sur notre chaîne YouTube allez on va
ouvrir une large page loisirs à présent
dans votre 7 8 à l'approche du weekend
prolongée de l'ascension nous vous
donnons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
avec vous Céline Charles qui avez-vous à
nous proposer ce soir alors Mathilde on
commence avec une pièce de théâtre elle
s'intitule je brasse de l'air c'est
vendredi et samedi au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans sa mise
en scène Magali Rousseau nous plonge
dans son univers celui de la mécanique
et de la machinerie donnant naissance à
toutes sortes d'objets inanimés c'est
dans un atelier où se trouve de drôle de
machine que se passe la pièce au son des
mécaniques fantaisistes des machines
c'est une histoire qui nous est racontée
et surtout une invitation à prendre son
envol un spectacle porté par des brides
de monologues tirés de souvenirs
d'enfance de la metteur en scène
regardez ma mère n'a jamais su nager
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'elle m'a
appris à voler
ne pas oublier
affronter les faux mouvements
[Musique]
maîtriser l'espace
éviter les chutes
alors après des années de mise en scène
c'est la première fois que Magali
Rousseau se met elle-même en scène au
côté de ses créations accessibles
décisant la pièce se joue trois fois par
jour vendredi et samedi au théâtre de 50
ans en Yvelines la suite en musique
Céline avec un événement phare dans le
sud des Yvelines et oui les amoureux de
la musique militaire ont rendez-vous ce
week-end à Rambouillet depuis l'an
dernier l'association phare 500 organise
des concerts pour faire renaître la
fanfare du saint santé unieme régiment
de chars de combat en garnison dissoute
en 1994 une cinquantaine de musiciens
composés d'anciens de la cavalerie
seront présents durant les deux concerts
gratuits les explications au micro de
Julien Leroy
[Musique]
c'est en fait une fanfare de cavalerie
qui rassemble uniquement des anciens
musiciens de la fanfare du 500 énième
régiment de Charles de combat en
garnison à Rambouillet jusqu'en 1994 en
fait date de dissolution de la fanfare
donc l'an dernier on a recréé voilà
cette association pour essayer de
refaire jouer tous les anciens musiciens
qui sont passés qui sont passés donc au
régiment dans ces années-là
[Musique]
on a recherché donc l'adjoint donc
Thierry Bergeot à de l'époque on l'a
retrouvé on lui a exposé notre projet et
il nous a dit ok vous êtes combien j'en
ai 30 mais il y a que 10 musiciens il y
a la fanfare c'était 45 musiciens à
l'époque il dit bah faut continuer à
chercher mais je vous suis à 200 % et
donc on a cherché et aujourd'hui on a
retrouvé 183 anciens musiciens donc qui
sont passés donc de 73 à 94 dernière
année et on est encore à peu près une
bonne soixantaine à jouer
[Musique]
ce sont des morceaux
forcément militaires très connu la
musique militaire mais pas que c'était
la particularité justement de cette
fanfare
Dume régiment Charles de combat où on
jouait aussi des morceaux un peu
exotiques on s'était assez nouveau dans
le milieu militaire et c'était une major
Souplet qui avait apporté ce renouveau
de la musique on va jouer des morceaux
je vais vous dire citer par exemple
trompette latino trompette Chacha voilà
ce sont et qui étaient joués à l'époque
lors de représentations on faisait pas
que du militaire
[Musique]
et pour terminer ces idées de sortie
Céline vous nous proposez du sport et
plus précisément du football à pratiquer
de manière originale oui le district des
Yvelines de football organise une
journée découverte autour à tous ouverte
à tous autour du foot ce jeudi des 13h30
en famille ou entre amis vous pourrez
découvrir plusieurs manières de jouer
avec le ballon rond comme le fitful le
golf foot ou encore le foot en marchant
ses activités font partie des nouvelles
pratiques de football en développement
au sein du district des Yvelines dans le
cadre du foot loisirs et bien hâte de
découvrir ce qu'est le golf le golfite
mais avant je tourne un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil continuera de
briller dans les Yvelines le ciel sera
légèrement voilée durant la matinée au
niveau des températures il fera 9 degrés
à Rambouillet ou dents et Versailles et
10 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi le temps devrait se
maintenir sur l'ensemble du département
côté température il fera en moyenne 15 à
16 degrés et pour les prévisions météo
de ce week-end si vous avez prévu de
faire le pont et de rester dans les
Yvelines les conditions seront
similaires à aujourd'hui et demain
vendredi le ciel sera dégagé avec des
températures le matin à 8 degrés et
l'après-midi à 15 degrés pour la journée
de samedi le soleil sera toujours au
beau fixe dans les Yvelines et les
températures se réchauffent avec 10
degrés en moyenne le matin et 16 degrés
en moyenne l'après-midi et enfin
dimanche conditions similaires pour
finir ce week-end prolongé en beauté du
soleil et des températures le matin à 12
degrés et l'après-midi à 17 degrés et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 7 et un bon week-end
prolongé si vous faites le pont merci à
vous prenez soin de vous
[Musique]